fue una noche a oscuras para millones de
ucranianos Y a esta hora del día todavía
se sigue sintiendo las consecuencias de
ese ataque masivo ayer de Rusia a
Ucrania con 70 misiles Y si bien 51 de
ellos fueron interceptados el resto
causó un daño inmenso nos encontramos en
la ciudad de Odessa que es la tercera
más grande del país y si bien aquí
anoche parte de la ciudad recuperó la
energía desde esta madrugada a otros
grandes sectores especialmente a las
afueras de la ciudad todavía se
encuentran a oscuras y lo mismo sucede
en la capital kiev que fue la que peor
vivió los ataques de ayer dos terceras
partes de la ciudad todavía se
encuentran sin energía y sin agua las
autoridades han dicho que esperan
ponerlo en reactivarlo a lo largo del
día Especialmente cuando entren en
actividades esas tres plantas nucleares
desconectadas pero las consecuencias han
sido grandes para
del país incluido las fronteras dos de
ellas dos pasos fronterizos con Hungría
y uno con Rumanía están no están
operando debido a esa falta de
Electricidad y las consecuencias también
se sintieron en el país vecino en
moldavia que también sufrió las
consecuencias Y tuvo una noche a oscuras
esto sucede en un momento cuando el
presidente
intervino ante el consejo de seguridad
de las Naciones Unidas en una
videollamada y dijo que lo que estaba
haciendo Rusia era una estrategia de
terror lo que estaba buscando era
congelar al resto de los ucranianos
Durante este invierno y dijo que esto
era un acto que iba en contra de los
Derechos Humanos aquí en la calle los
ucranianos piensan que esta es una
manera que Rusia está dando está
haciendo para humillarlos pero también
para llevarlos a una mesa de negociación
pero muchos aquí piensan que todavía las
condiciones no están dadas